touristes tués dont beaucoup de français
jimmy carter les procès de moscou menace
la détente
les quatre dissidents devant leurs juges
et sans défenseur pour la première fois
depuis la libération
dix mille manifestants tout d'opinions
politiques confondues à paris
négociations dans la fonction publique
accor en série jacques dominati le sens
de ce dégel sociale là messieurs bonsoir
ce qui s'est passé tout à l'heure en
début d'après midi en espagne près de
tarragone est vraiment épouvantables il
n'y a pas d'autres mots pour le
qualifier 180 morts peut être 200 dans
un camping au bord de la mer un camp où
se retrouvaient en majorité des
étrangers des touristes français
allemands et dans une moindre mesure
belges britanniques et néerlandais
vous avez bien entendu 200 morts c'est
un camion citerne chargé de propane qui
a explosé aux environs de 15 heures
le camping était complet c'était là-bas
l'heure de la sieste les premiers
témoignages des rares survivants sont
effroyables un souffle comparable à une
explosion atomique des automobiles des
caravanes des hommes des femmes des
enfants soufflé vers la mer
un cratère de plusieurs mètres de
profondeur et d'une vingtaine de mètres
de diamètre et puis vous l'imaginez des
réactions en chaîne c'est-à-dire des
explosions de bouteilles de gaz butane
dans les caravanes dans les tentes
aggravant et incendiant ce qui avait été
épargnée tout cela s'est donc passé je
vous le répète près de centre carlos de
la rapid à vous le voyez dans le camping
de l'os olfa caisse sur la route
notre envoyé spécial permanent en
espagne bruno albouy noir
tout est fait qu'une partie de la
citerne a explosé à l'intérieur du camp
type de camper a volé en éclats et que
le plus gros morceau de cette idée avait
été retrouvé à plusieurs centaines de
mètres de l'endroit de la catastrophe
un dancing qui était très très proches
du terrain de camping à lui été
littéralement souffrez bilan restauré
heureusement rien que si loi 204 en
avant est pour l'instant provisoire il a
été confirmée tout à l'heure par la
garde civile mais ce nom que telle ou
telle et que le nombre des blessés est
très important et que les saisons pour
la tête un matin de brouilly intégrale
de l'ordre de 50 à 80 %
ces prix malheureusement présager que la
ligne 2 est mort sera encore plus longue
que ne l'est actuellement
actuellement les l'autorité du cognaçais
sont en train d'essayer de rassembler
sur l'ailé des catastrophes matelly mode
hélicoptères pour transporter les
blessés étaient tous les quartiers de la
capitale
on peut dire voilà temps provisoire oui
180 morts parmi lesquels nous vous
l'avons dit beaucoup de français pour
l'instant bien évidemment ne connaissons
pas le détail ce que nous pouvons
essayer d'imaginer pendant que bruno
albin est en train de regagner valence
il est à quelques km matin à l'endroit
de la catastrophe il va peut-être nous
rejoindre avant la fin de ce journal est
bien ce qu on peut peut-être voir avec
vos georges leclercq ccc la cause de cet
accident c'est d'abord se profilait
n'est pas du propane ont alors dit le
propylène est un liquide industriel
d'origine pétrolière il n'a rien à voir
avec le gaz propane de vos bouteilles
pet tissu chimiquement du gaz propane
mais il n'a rien à voir vous n'avez en
principe pas du tout de propylène chez
vous n'avez aucune raison d'en avoir
il s'agit d'un produit très courant
raffinerie qui se transporte sans arrêt
tu ne raffinera une autre ce qui prouve
que les pas très dangereux quand on le
manipule bien mais chez vous vous n'avez
pas donc ne craignez rien deuxièmement
ce propylène qui est encore assez
difficile à obtenir il est fabriqué par
vapocraquage dans les grandes
raffineries ouailles on craque de
pétrole nafta pour obtenir ce ce
propylène il sert à beaucoup de choses
des matières plastiques des détergents
des additifs dans les lubrifiants voyez
donc pourquoi il est très
très courant mais on a demandé aux
pompiers s'il connaissait ce produit
vous voyez comme produits dangereux ils
nous ont dit bien sûr il est classé dans
la même catégorie que le kérosène avec
deux très gros danger premièrement quand
il se mélange à l'air il ya risque
d'explosion un peu comme tous les
hydrocarbures l'essence etc
deuxièmement quand il était chauffé
entre 50 et 100 degrés il peut exploser
c'est probablement un de des deux
scénarios qui a dû se passer avec la
citerne
alors autant qu'on sache pour l'instant
cette citerne ne vais pas être dans le
camp elle l'était ça tellement rumeurs
sur une route le lorrain quand ils
sentent d'être mort se soient détachés
et aient abouti finalement dans le
camping provoquant ces 200 morts il a
fait exploser avant d'être détaché ou
après ça je ne sais pas mais ce ya une
chose que très grave c'est que quand le
propylène kita liquide s'enflamme et
explose il est projetée partout il
devient gazeux il est très difficile de
les teindre si vous l'avez sur vous
c'est presque comme le naval de la
guerre voyait enfin toutes proportions
gardées les tentes ont dû brûler les
gens aussi donc les brûlures des blessés
sont très très grave yahia cache une
seule solution se sentir et c'est très
très grandes quantités d'eau pulvérisé
mais on ne les avait pas là bas bien je
vous le répète donc bruno albin n'est
plus qu'à quelques kilomètres de
l'endroit de cette catastrophe
il va sans doute nous appeler d'ici à la
fin de ce journal en attendant bien
évidemment dès que nous savons quelque
chose
nous vous informons en attendant et
c'est aussi la loi de l'actualité le
reste des informations à l'étranger à
commencer par la suite des procès
soviétique ce que l'on appelle la saison
des juges les procès qui donne lieu à
une succession d'incidents à l'âme
gainsbourg la femme de l'accusé de
kalouga a été cet après-midi expulsé du
tribunal non loin de là à vilnius le
procès du dissident lituanie 1 victor
cactus a été suspendue au bout d'une
heure et demie enfin un moscou deuxième
journée du procès sharansky son épouse
vera après-demain saracens le socket à
d'état américain si vous voulez
l'équivalent de notre ministre des
affaires étrangères
le procès d'un atoll sharansky devant la
chambre criminelle de la cour suprême de
moscou se déroule toujours à huis clos
ainsi la mère de charance lit que l'on
voit ici s'est vu refuser l'accès du
tribunal de même les journalistes
occidentaux doivent se contenter de
filmer les abords du palais de justice
et d'assister aux conférences de presse
des porte parole officiel aujourd'hui la
cour a examiné les accusations
d'espionnage portées contre challans qui
d'après son frère seul membre de la
famille y avoir d assister aux débats
sharansky paraît en bonne forme et sûr
de lui il a récusé l'avocat commis
d'office et assure désormais seule sa
propre défense
il peut s'exprimer devant la cour sans
être un terreau toujours selon son frère
charles ans qui a refusé de reconnaître
sa culpabilité et a qualifié les
accusations portées contre lui d'
absurde
il a refusé par avance de répondre à des
questions sur ses relations avec les
étrangers et affirmé que son action en
faveur de l'immigration des juifs
soviétiques étaient justifiées par les
termes de l'accord d'helsinki
georges bartoli est ce qu'on peut
essayer de comprendre pourquoi y ait eu
procès pour quelques cas de procès en
même temps je veux dire d'abord que les
phénomènes de dissidence prennent
actuellement une ampleur telle qu'il
inquiète vraiment les dirigeants
soviétiques ce n'est pas une inquiétude
face c'est une véritable inquiétude il
ya quelques jours sur une grande route
près de kalouga précisément la ville où
on est en train de juger alexandre
guinzbourg il y avait une inscription
sur la chaussée abba brejnev
or vous savez moi j'ai parcouru pas mal
les routes soviétique il faudra pas mal
d'années je n'ai jamais vu d'inscription
comme ça j'avais même un détail
courteline est ce que c'est que la
peinture était le tellement bonne
qualité qu'on n'arrivait pas à faire
partir d'inscription alors on a cassé le
macadam ou au marteau piqueur donc
devant une montée de la dissidence de
l'esprit contestataire si vous voulez et
bien les autorités soviétiques font un
exemple
quatre procès simultanées et puis ce
n'est pas sans conséquence sur le front
international sur toi quelques jours la
rencontre 25 gros micro à genève
imaginez c'est un moyen de chantage
écoutez c'est très curieux parce que les
soviétiques savent tout de même très
très bien que lorsque l'on parle de
violation des droits de l'homme à jimmy
carter jimmy carter réagit un petit peu
comme le taureau à qui on montre le
rouge il fonce effectivement il a foncé
il a dit que les états unis pourraient
reconsidérer leurs relations avec l'urss
il est mécontent il le dit sans
ménagement fin avec un ménagement tout
de même il a fait dire qu' il n'était
pas question de reporter les
négociations vince gromyko sur le
désarmement mais c'est tout de même une
menace d' escalade dans ce que monsieur
brejnev lui-même a appelé la guerre
fraîche et les soviétiques savais que ça
allait se passer ils ont pris le risque
donc de déclencher cela d'autant que
partout dans le monde vous le disiez
cette série de procès a suscité
l'indignation des manifestations de
soutien ont été organisées dans la
plupart des démocraties aux états unis
en israël bien sûr je vous rappelle qu'à
nathalie sharon ce qui est juif et
qu'ils voulaient immigrer là bas enfin à
paris depuis un peu plus d'une heure m
peut-être un millier de personnes
aujourd'hui à cette manifestation ce qui
prouve si c'était nécessaire combien les
français sont sensibles à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui à moscou
beaucoup de particuliers sans étiquette
ni syndicale ni politique
mais le plus surprenant reste que pour
la première fois ça nous a paris une
manifestation réunit autour de madame
sharansky autant de couleurs politiques
différentes
ps le mouvement d'extrême gauche
mouvements antiracistes cds un
républicain indépendant syndicats de
toutes tendances et le parti communiste
représenter sans les têtes des plus
importantes mais tout de même avec le
délégué du pc à paris on constatera que
le parti communiste en pleine conformité
avec sa politique intervient pour
défendre la liberté partout elle mls ont
un peu l'impression
on a un peu l'impression que vous êtes
un peu contraint et forcé par l'opinion
publique
c'est aussi à cette manifestation c'est
une erreur complète nous sommes
contraints à participer à toute action
en faveur de la liberté par notre propre
politique par notre propre détermination
pour nous la démocratie et le but à
atteindre
elle est aussi le moyen d'y parvenir
nous récusons catégoriquement toute
notion qui tendrait à envisager le
socialisme autrement que dans le pvp
louis span la liberté c'est notre
politique pour notre pays c'est aussi le
coin de rue pour tous les pays du globe
là il a fait ne se partage pas
aux etats unis les réactions au procès
des dissidents sont très vives tant à
washington qu'à new york il ya eu des
manifestations
le bureau de l'aéro flotte à new york a
été plastiquée une motion était soumise
au sénat qui exigerait la suspension
immédiate des échanges culturels et
scientifiques avec l'urss et l'arrêt des
négociations sur les armements
stratégiques
enfin le président carter qui va envoyer
une lettre de protestation elle est une
vraie genève a laissé entendre que les
etats-unis seraient amenés à réviser
leur attitude vis-à-vis d'union
soviétique
un porte-parole a même suggéré que les
états unis pourraient boycotter les jeux
olympiques de 1980 qui doit se tenir à
moscou vive émotion en israël où des
milliers de personnes sont venues prier
pour charance lier les autres accusés
devant le mur des lamentations à
jérusalem
les manifestations se sont également
déroulées à tel-aviv au parlement les
députés ont adopté une motion condamnant
les procès de moscou et demandant au
président carter d'adopter une attitude
très ferme face à l'union soviétique
le premier ministre belge guy n'a
affirmé que seuls jimmy carter par une
intervention directe auprès d'eux léonid
brejnev pourrait sauver la vie d'anatole
sharansky et bien précisément demain
dans notre journal de 20h jimmy carter
évoquera pour un thème de la position
américaine sur les dissidents et sur
leur traitement l'urss qui me carter y
répondra en exclusivité aux questions de
notre envoyé spécial permanent jacques
séguin à quelques jours du sommet de
bonnes et c'est de là ce sommet que nous
consacrons d'ailleurs notre magazine du
soir question de temps son titre des
dollars et des hommes c'est par amour
pour moscou qu'un grand résistant
français tombés pour espionnage il
s'appelle georges beau fils il a 66 ans
il est jugé en ce moment par la cour de
sûreté de l'état jugé pour intelligence
avec des agents de puissances étrangères
en termes moins pompeux il a fourni des
renseignements confidentiels aux agents
soviétiques et l'on se demande on peut
se demander en tout cas laurent socan
comment un héros de la dernière guerre
peut tout d'un coup devenir espion un
véritable héros il faut le dire l'homme
qui comparaît devant la cour sécurité de
l'état
à la croix de guerre à la médaille de la
résistance à la légion d'honneur ça a
été un compagnon de chaban-delmas là
étaient présentes et félicité par
général de gaulle un véritable héros
alors effectivement comment est ce
possible parce que au lendemain de la
résistance de cette grande résistance
qui la fait bien vos fils continue
s'engage dans l'armée fut une école
d'officiers et ils commandent même en 2d
un régiment de zouaves à tunis et nous
sommes en 52 or d'un seul coup en 1952
il est mis au rancart c'est le terme et
est juste car c'est comme ça qu'ils leur
sang à cause de ses opinions
communisante alors il le dit lui-même il
a le sentiment de pourrir sur pied cet
homme qu un homme actif cet homme qui a
eu l'impression de faire l'histoire d'un
seul coup l'impression tout s'écroule
autour de lui qui ne sert plus à rien
qu'on ne s'occupe plus de lui et il se
trouve des agents soviétiques et c'est
ça qui est intéressant pour le savoir
pour sentir cette faille qui avait un
terrain voilà il alors au cours d'une
réunion d'un cocktail pour
l'anniversaire de réduction d'octobre 64
des journalistes soit disant journaliste
vietti clap roche et discute avec lui le
félicite le flat qui donne l'impression
qu'il est important lui par la sphère
militaire comme si son opinion comptait
encore mieux que cela n ses journalistes
un jour l'invite à aller dans sa datcha
à moscou tous frais payés et en une
journée il y obtient un visa il se méfie
pas il y va alors il revoit ses
journalistes qui lui demandaient
renseignements qui lui demandent des
documents qui lui demandent des livres
plus ou moins confidentielles et or
voyez peu à peu ça monte d'un cran d'un
cran d'un cran et peut-être au début ne
se rende et type pas compte de ce qu'ils
faisaient
et lorsque d'un seul coup alors on en
arrive à ces pauvres au monde espionnage
presque de série b
lorsque tout à coup on lui donne un
poste pour capter les messages secrets
il reconnaît ces messages en écoutant
inverse des fleurs du mal de baudelaire
lorsqu'on lui donne par exemple info
extincteurs d'incendié creux des
microfilms enfin tout le mariage de
james bond
alors sans doute c'est trop tard il est
pris dans le dans le réseau il ne peut
plus aller à l'arrière il lui faudra des
des années qu'on s'en dégager entre
temps il sera peut-être devenu année
puis on c'est une tragédie donc georges
beaufils jugé en ce moment par la cour
de sûreté de l'état
plus qu'une faille en abyme l'albanie
est aujourd'hui plus isolé que jamais
elle est doublement est assez doucement
en train de rompre ses liens avec la
chine pékin en effet aujourd'hui
interrompue sur l'assistance économique
et cela suit de près le début querelles
idéologiques
les chinois ont décidé de rappeler leurs
techniciens à tirana
la chine qui par ailleurs est toujours
en conflit mais beaucoup plus ouvert
avec le vietnam hanoi annonce que
plusieurs avions de chasse chinois ont
violé il y a trois jours son espace
aérien mauritanie et bien la situation
est calme à nouakchott la capitale les
aéroports doivent réouvrir demain le
couvre-feu est abrégé et l'on ne perçoit
pas d'agitation dans les rues sadi on
s'interroge toujours sur les motivations
du gouvernement mauritanien huit
militaires et huit civils toutes les
capitales voisines restent sur une
prudente expectative et l'on ne sait pas
toujours quelle sera l'attitude du
nouvel homme fort du pays monsieur salek
à l'égard des rebelles sahraoui
c'est la guérilla menée par le front
polisario depuis près de trois ans qui a
précipité la chute du régime de moktar
ould daddah
les dirigeants du front polisario ont à
plusieurs reprises affirmé qu'il
recherchait la déstabilisation de la
mauritanie sont arrivés à leur but en
asphyxiant économiquement le pays
la grande richesse de la mauritanie
étant le minerai de fer de zuera tu ils
n'ont pas cessé d'harceler militairement
le train qui de zohra nuisibles sur
l'océan atlantique était le cordon
ombilical du pays
l'exploitation devenant de plus en plus
difficile l'économie du pays a sombré
créant un énorme malaise social et un
mécontentement général de la population
avalant la plupart des devises pour
acheter de l'armement et créer une armée
moderne le trésor mauritanien était
pratiquement en cessation de paiement
les soldes des militaires et d'autres
fonctionnaires n'étaient plus payés
depuis plusieurs mois les sympathiques
du front polisario ne s'est elle pas
retourner aujourd'hui contre lui inquiet
de l'évolution de la situation du
pourrissement intérieur pour prévenir
des mots encore plus grand et éviter
l'arrivée au pouvoir paiement de gauche
révolutionnaire les véritables
instigateurs de ce coup d'état
ne serait-il pas les marocains et des
services de renseignement occident
peut-être et rien n'est véritablement
joué car en afrique quand on entre dans
le cycle des coups d'état militaires et
retournements d'alliance sont
imprévisibles
espagne toujours avec une actualité bien
sûr d'une tout autre dimension que celle
que nous allons évoquer à nouveau tout à
leur journée ville morte à pampelune
dans le pays basque
des funérailles impressionnantes ont été
réservées aux jeunes militants
séparatistes tué par la police samedi
plus de dix mille personnes derrière le
cercueil recouvrant le leurs couverts
pardon du drapeau de letea la situation
reste tendue des manifestations dans
plusieurs villes ont d'ailleurs provoqué
de nouveaux incidents avec les forces de
l'ordre ce matin encore un mort et
plusieurs blessés au cours
d'affrontements à san sébastian et à
l'est toujours d'ailleurs à l'heure
actuelle des barricades dans les rues de
la ville de san sebastian pour a terminé
tout à fait avec l'actualité à
l'étranger j'ajoute que les douaniers
italiens sont à nouveau en grève
400 camions sont immobilisés depuis ce
matin depuis le tunnel du mont blanc
avait pu voir depuis le début de ce
journal derrière moi une intense
activité toujours porté restait de
téléphoner en espagne près de tarragone
pour essayer de savoir ce qui s'est
passé réellement quel est le nombre des
morts et des blessés dans l'explosion de
ce camping est bien un noël mamère a
réussi a donc centraliser tous ces
renseignements
et il semble noël que la situation sera
vraiment dramatique aussi bien pour les
quelques survivants que pour les laisser
car les prix sont très graves matin oui
il ya plus de 70 blessés qui ont été
réceptionnés dans les différents
hôpitaux qui environnent tarragone et
selon les médecins de ses hôpitaux ses
70 blessés n'ont pratiquement aucune
chance de survie la plupart sont brûlés
à 100%
et rappelons que le premier bilan d'un
appel pressent la deux en or à peu près
et puis tout à l'heure vous évoquez avec
georges leclercq les conditions de cet
accident
vous disiez que la citerne s'était
détachée du camion c'est effectivement
ce qui s'est passé sur cette route
nationale qui est très empruntée par
beaucoup de camions de fruits et légumes
et beaucoup de camions citernes sept
sites ainsi donc détachés elle est allée
à l'heure en pointe et une course folle
jusqu'au centre du camping et c'est là
qu'elle a explosé précisément et selon
certains témoignages
disque ça ressemble à une explosion
atomique je vous rappelle que nous
espérons toujours à voir bruno alvin
tout à l'heure en direct des lieux de la
catastrophe car il se trouve qu'à
quelques kilomètres de ce camping est
donc passons maintenant à l'actualité
française avec le dossier numéro 1 une
manifestation très spectaculaire de la
crypte des chantiers navals 13 147
licenciements annoncés à la ciotat soit
à peu près un salarié sur trois ou
quatre ce qui est énorme et si les
carnets de commandes ne sont pas mieux
remplies le chiffre pourrait s'alourdir
encore plus tard les syndicats soutenus
par la municipalité communiste appelle
d'ailleurs les employés à débrayer et à
manifester demain matin ce navire est là
des six derniers en construction au
chantier de la ciotat qui n'ont pas reçu
de commandes depuis quatre ans la crise
est mondiale même les numéros 1 les
japonais sont touchés mais la france
avec près du quart des commandes en
moins en 1977 et accuse une chute deux
fois plus importante que dans le monde
en général
or chez nous la construction navale
emploie soixante mille personnes à
nantes par exemple aujourd'hui la
direction de dubigeon normandie annonce
une réduction de la durée hebdomadaire
du travail
mais la région la plus touchée c'est la
méditerranée à la ciotat les chantiers
font vivre la moitié est salarié de la
commune or après 300 mises en
préretraite la suppression des 13 cents
emplois annoncée pour le 1er octobre
fait qu'au total près du tiers du
personnel aura disparu cette année
mesure inévitable pour la direction qui
en attend un sursis mossad oserait
conscient avec 6000 emplois d'être le
plus gros employeurs de la métallurgie
dans le département la ciotat de
tradition un chantier naval mais enfin
l'occupé 4000 4500 personnes jusqu'en 68
pendant dix ans nous avons pu tenir ce
niveau d'emploi de 6000 nous voudrions
le tenir plus longtemps nous espérons
retire dans le futur mais enfin il faut
être à l'évidence aujourd'hui nous
devons faire un repli stratégique et je
crois que notre premier devoir c'est de
sauver d'abord les 4500 emplois qu'on
peut peut-être espérer sauver dans cette
période difficile si on s'accroche si on
se bat et si on réduit son activité au
niveau que nous avons choisie qui nous
paraît être le minimum possible
les syndicats demandent à l'état
d'intervenir pour les élus locaux il
faut obliger les armateurs qui reçoivent
des aides gouvernementales à construire
français c'est elles atteignent 20 % du
prix des navires les alors que l' ocde
préconise une réduction de leur activité
la france peut-elle subventionner ces
chantiers après le secteur privé les
premiers accords de salaires des modes
être signé dans le secteur public et
nationalisé par l'ensemble des syndicats
sauf la cgt et la cfdt
vous citez vendredi le cas de la
fonction publique et bien aujourd'hui
c'est au tour de la sncf
quatre organisations syndicales ont
signé l'accord salarial sont 18
dans les deux cas maintien du pouvoir
d'achat et progression plus importante
des bas salaires ce qui est important
c'est que il y ait non seulement des
garanties mais qu'il est une progression
s'il n'y avait pas d'accord du tout eh
bien le gouvernement bien entendu
continuerait à gérer il ferait son
travail
mais est-ce qu'il irait au delà alors
ces accords sur les salaires
apparaissent et on peut se demander
pourquoi davantage comme un succès pour
le gouvernement que pour les syndicats
pour ma part je ne le crois pas je crois
vraiment que c'est un succès pour les
syndicats
c'est un succès pour les syndicats dans
la mesure où il
ils ont très bien compris les syndicats
qu'en ce qui concerne la fonction
publique il fallait sortir de
excusez-moi l'expression mais du
cimetière vraiment du cimetière et c'est
un nouveau départ c'est u c'est à mon
sens pour la fonction publique
une ère nouvelle à la fois de recherche
de progression
je ne dirais pas de concertation mais de
dialogue et je suis persuadé que les
syndicats signataires qui ont rendez
vous avec moi en novembre pour faire le
point leurs visages ainsi et c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles la cgc par
exemple a signé des accords pour vous il
ya une nouvelle atmosphère dans la
politique disons contractuels ah j'en
suis persuadé j'étais très étonnée je ne
vous cache pas de du contact que j'ai eu
avec les syndicats je dirais avec tous
les syndicats de la fonction publique et
c'est une atmosphère
je ne sais pas si les nouvelles puisque
le sien nouveaux ministres en tout cas
je suis agréablement surpris le parrain
tout à l'heure d'un secteur en crise
celui des chantiers navals en voici un
autre bâtiment un secteur qui fait
travailler plus d'un million de
personnes et biens en quatre ans il a
perdu 15% de ses salariés
le gouvernement a décidé de réagir
michel d'ornano a annoncé le déblocage
de 7 milliards de francs de crédits pour
l'accession à la propriété qui devrait
permettre la construction de 25 25 mille
logements donc donner du travail à cette
industrie
c'est un premier pas dans la bonne
direction dit la fédération nationale du
bâtiment
l'union des hlm quant à elle juge ces
mesures trop timide
elle pense qu'en tout état de cause
elles ne pourront pas enrayer la crise
qui menace ce secteur économique
quinze mille emplois donc supprimée en
quatre ans redéployer l'économie c'est
agir sur de nombreux leviers
certains commande l'ensemble des
secteurs d'activité on peut par exemple
abaissé le levier fiscal et allégé les
impôts les entreprises ou bien et c'est
le choix actuel de raymond barre relâché
le levier prix en libérant notamment les
prix industriels
on pourrait aussi agir sur le levier qui
commande un seul secteur mais un secteur
clé ainsi si l'on trouvait le moyen de
relancer le bâtiment c'est un souffle
d'air frais qui passeraient sur de très
vastes secteurs économiques
en effet le bâtiment fait travailler des
centaines de milliers de salariés qui
lui sont propres mais aussi l'industrie
du ciment
la sidérurgie pour les fers à béton le
vert pour les fenêtres etc
en aval la construction des meubles le
sanitaire l'électroménager dépendent
étroitement de l'activité du bâtiment à
travers ses effets induits la relance de
ce secteur apparaît d'autant plus
nécessaire aux professionnels voici un
exemple de ces effets induits indirects
c'est le chantier d'une entreprise dite
de secondes donc en aval des
constructeurs chauffage climatisation
une entreprise moyenne
son chiffre d'affaires est tombé de
moitié en deux ans 20 % de personnel en
moins et cette entreprise fait elle même
travaillé une foule de sous traitants et
de fournisseurs qui fabrique par exemple
les canalisations les chaudières ses
fournisseurs à leur tour achète de
l'acier et caetera et c'est
l'enchaînement est semblable en amour
les constructeurs où l'on trouve autres
les fabricants de ciment la douze mille
salariés un chiffre d'affaires qui
baissent régulièrement depuis quatre ans
alors après c'est nous ça suppose qu'une
relance d'un bâtiment et travaux publics
alors c'est un secteur qui est lourd un
secteur difficile parce qu'il dépend
essentiellement de décision des pouvoirs
publics étant données les systèmes des
deux logements et les systèmes de
décision pour les investissements
publics qui font marcher des travaux
publics
c'est pratiquement suspendu à des
décisions de caractère national une
incitation nationale devrait bien su
réagir tout au début de cette chaîne au
maillon étroitement liés et ce début de
chaîne c'est la demande les besoins de
construction où en sont ses besoins la
reconstruction d'après guerre est
terminée depuis longtemps le boom
immobilier les années 60 aussi est
certain aujourd'hui pensent que le
marché au moins en france est en voie de
saturation mais ce n'est pas l'avis de
tout le monde il est besoin en wc vous
savez c'est du gadget c'est de la libye
c'est à la limite de l'hypocrisie
on ya quatre ans lorsque tout d'un coup
les la crise du pétrole tout d'un coup
paraît-il les besoins du bâtiment
il y en avait plus en fait vous savez
les gens ne regardent que les
statistiques
les statistiques ne marque pas ce que
sont les besoins les statistiques marque
l'argent qu'on a mis à la disposition
d'un secteur et aussi les obstructions
des mécanismes d un kbis administratif
en fait devant la chute de la demande
naturelle spontanée ce que réclament les
professionnels du bâtiment c'est une
demande nouvelle provoqué par l'état
bref c'est à la forte de raymond barre
que l'on frappe et au lendemain d'un
conseil interministériel qui s'est
penché sur la question sans rien
promettre
raymond barre ne paraît pas disposé à
ouvrir largement le cap général demeure
celui de la croissance faible la relance
attendra le bâtiment sans doute aussi
un an de prison pour gilbert zemmour
ainsi en a décidé la troisième chambre
correctionnelle de paris un jugement qui
sanctionne les menaces de mort sous
condition la famille zemmour avait été
souvent inquiété pour divers trafics
mais jamais véritablement accroché par
la justice le tour de france maintenant
étape capitale aujourd'hui entre pau et
saint lary soulan s'il faut la résumer
quatre gros titres bruyère toujours
maillot jaune le français martinez
vainqueur du jour
bernard hinault second à 5 secondes en
forme magnifique
enfin la chute d'un champion bernard
thévenet qui à bout de force a fini par
abandonner dans l'ascension du tourmalet
voici le belge michel pollentier son
attaque à cinq kilomètres de l'arrivée a
semblé un moment condamné bernard
hinault mais le champion de france sans
s'affoler refait son retard ici et paul
entier doit cette fois s'accrocher à sa
roue chaque jour hinault étonne
davantage
et paul entier et donc dans sa roue la
fin de l'étape il l'accomplît en
compagnie du champion de belgique mais
aussi de yachts melk et de mariano
martin est martinez lui ne prend pas les
relais il est donc plus frais que ses
compagnes cela va lui servir car
regardez bien ici sur la droite il
attaque il démarre nous sommes à
quelques mètres seulement une centaine
de mètres de l'arrivée
arrivé donc de cette première étape de
montagne martinez va conserver quelques
secondes d'avancé sur la ligne alors que
zoetemelk a semblé en difficulté
bruyère nous l'avons dit va garder son
beau maillot jaune pour quelques jours
encore sans doute mais déjà l'on peut
dire que hyper évents nîmes ont perdu le
tour de france que bernard hinault
s'apprête à gagner
mariano martinez le smicard du peloton
l'emportent ici confirmant ses biens
belles qualités de grimpeur
classement général voici donc quatre
coureurs dans des mouchoirs bruyère
hinault ou hotmail pollentier auxquels
il faut ajouter l'hollandais cuyper qui
n'est pas loin curieuse ironie du sort
nous l'avons dit l'ascension de bernard
hinault qui semble irrésistible diffusée
l'après-midi coïncide avec la défiance
de bernard thévenet
on a vraiment eu l'impression
aujourd'hui qu'à un grand champion
français passer le relais à un autre
nous sommes dans la dernière étape du
tour de france 1973
bernard thévenet réalise un petit
exploit
il s'est échappé aux abords du vélodrome
de la cipale à paris il est alors
champion de france et il va gagner
l'étape
terminer deuxième de ce tour de france à
15 minutes de luis ocaña
on décèle en lui les toffes d'un futur
vainqueur du tour il devra attendre deux
ans 1975 pour l'emporter
l'arrivée ayant lieu pour la première
fois sur les champs-elysées
et déjà on constate que les années
paires le sont guère favorables aux
bourguignons en 1975 il est le premier à
vaincre eddy merckx dans le tour de
france en 1976 le dicton est respectée
c'est une nouvelle année noire et
thévenet revient en vainqueur au tour
sur les champs 1977
on a eu très peur pour lui car une chute
l'a précipité au sol avec bon nombre de
concurrents
la route était très glissante est très
dangereux
au terme de la grande boucle thévenet
précède au long des quais hyper de 48
secondes
mais depuis cette victoire thévenet n'a
pas réalisé de grandes choses
1978 il est vrai est une année paire
jean-michel leulliot était avec bernard
thévenet à midi lors de son abandon
j'ai toujours l'impression du fer à
mieux jeu se poursuivre la course
on a vu hier je m'en contenterai mais
mam entend moins vite que les mêmes
symptômes est un avion discuté hier avec
le docteur mireille m'avait dit de
repartir aujourd'hui mais j'ai dit les
mêmes symptômes se produisait
l'encastrement evans le mieux s'arrêter
par le repos maintenant c'est l'abandon
leur deux roues il ne reproche pas ce
que beaucoup besoin de retrouver surtout
la tête non avoir une méchante retour
fait surtout au besoin de repos moral et
nerveux surtout les années paires ne
marche pas les années impaires rendez
vous entre 112 mais oui enfin toute
façon en devoir 79 bien sûr mais après
tout la crise n'est pas finie en 76
jugent abandonnés dans le tour après je
sais bien marché en fin de saison
j'espère que cette année sera pareil
parce que je le dois bien tous les gens
qui m'ont encouragé tout au long de la
route
voilà il puis football assez rapidement
tirage au sort des premiers matches des
coupes européennes vous allez voir
découvrir dans un instant donc la coupe
des clubs champions monaco rencontrera
bucarest et 16 et 30 août la coupe des
vainqueurs de coupes l'as nancy lorraine
rencontrera le vainqueur de la coupe du
danemark dans la coupe de l'uefa nantes
aura affaire à forte partie benfica
lisbonne et 13 et 27 septembre enfin
strasbourg rencontrera un autre danois
helle spork le temps maintenant une fois
de plus et toujours inhabituellement
froid et pluvieux pour la saison
aujourd'hui des nuages sur toute la
france des orages sur l'ouest quelques
rafales de vent au sud pour demain bien
peu de changements hélas les brumes
matinales feront place à un ciel de plus
en plus nuageux sur la moitié ouest de
la france
le temps restera variable avec des
ondées des éclaircies des orages sur les
massifs montagneux
ils ont aussi que les températures
maximum seront en hausse
voilà bruno albin viennent me rappelait
il y à quelques minutes
il est tout près des lieux de la
catastrophe c'est à dire à san carlos de
la rapid à il a voulu imaginer les pires
difficultés pour pénétrer car il ya
beaucoup de barrages de police autour
mais ils viennent me confirmer que dans
une heure à peu près à 21h30
nous recevrons des images de cette
catastrophe donc dans ce camping qui a
fait plus de 200 morts
200 morts avec beaucoup de touristes
français belges et allemands et que donc
nous aurons ces images aux besoins et
avec l'autorisation bien sûr darmangeat
mouillé de l'équipe des dossiers de
l'écran nous interrompre le cours normal
de nos émissions pour vous montrer ces
images en provenance d'espagne
voilà votre dernier rendez vous en tout
est à creuser vers 23h40 avec hervé
claude bonne soirée à tous à demain